one of my favorite studies that isn't
very well known he gets a large group of
people shows them an e-commerce site and
for every purchaser one of the items
they're trying to buy just isn't there
now sometimes on the site it's labeled
as unavailable other people see sold out
when he questions those groups as to how
irritate they are with the website he
sees a swing of 15 with the people who
see unavailable being the most irritated
people who see sold out the least
irritated if the website emphasizes
unavailable they're emphasizing their
logistical attitude if the website
emphasizes sold out they're emphasizing
how popular this product is people do
not experience events they experience
the description of events and if you
just change that description you can
radically change people's reaction
so the last episode that we did we
managed to get through eight out of 16
and a half psychological biases from
your fantastic new book which is now out
and people should go and buy right now
I like that as a bit of advice yep yes
the First new this is half of a half of
an Insight base value neglect what's
that
um so it's an idea here that
people when they are weighing up numbers
essentially respond to them naively
so if you
um show people a you know a bowl of
jelly beans for example and one of the
ten beans is a is a red bean and you
tell people that
um they will get a cash reward for
picking a red bee you give them the
option of picking from either a
10 bean jar with one red or a hundred
bean jar with eight Reds
you find that people will mistakenly
want to pick from the larger number so
even though the absolute chance of
winning drops the fact that there are
literally more beans uh perverts the
their decision making
so so people react to the number rather
than what the number represents I think
that's where we're getting to with this
idea uh because eight sounds like more
than one but it's eight out of a hundred
as opposed to one out of ten
exactly exactly so if you're a marketer
you can start to harness that idea to
your to your benefit so there's a lovely
study from Gonzalez who's at a gay
business school and she came up with a
study where she shows some people a uh
pack of balloons for 48 pesos some
people see a 12 peso discount some CA 25
discount and in that scenario people
prefer the 25 discount even though they
are mathematically the same other set of
people she shows a jacket for 480 pesos
some people see a 120 peso discount some
people see a 25 discount now the group
that see the 120 peso discount rate it
as a better deal than the group that saw
the 25 percent
discount so once again people are
reacting to the size of the number
rather than what that number represents
so Jonah Berger heard about this study
and he has a wonderful pithy Turner
phrase he said that there is a rule of a
hundred if you're
selling a product that costs more than a
hundred pounds or 100 or 100 euros you
should talk about your absolute
discounts if you're selling a product
that costs less than 100 you should talk
about the percentage discount you know
that way you're always tapping into this
this insight didn't you find something
to do with why bonuses are more
effective than discounts as well
yes so really similar set of ideas here
so there is a lovely rail study from
2012 where they sell hand lotion in a
pharmacy for 16 weeks sometimes they
refer to it as a 35 discount sometimes
they refer to it as 50 more and what
they find is that on the weeks that they
talk about it being 50 more there are 81
more sales now even though these two
things are mathematically the same
people cannot help to react to the scale
of the number rather than what that
number represents so it's interesting
there because most brands most
advertisers are fixated with talking
about discounts what rail study suggests
is you should contemplate talk about
value-added you know Bonus Pack you're
getting more because that will always be
a larger absolute number it sounds like
it sounds like this is it's it's how the
discounts make people feel it's like
what what does this mean for me yeah
that's a really nice way of putting I
think that's a better way of putting it
in fact because
what it gets to is a fundamental insight
about how people make small commercial
decisions that they don't weigh up these
purchases in a fully considered way they
don't spend you know minutes upon
minutes weighing up their shampoo
purchase
um working out whether this is an
amazing deal because frankly if you
spent that long on every purchase you
would grind to a hole in life so instead
what people do is they make faster snap
decisions now some people call those
emotional decisions but really they're
just about it's about speed it's about
an immediate response and what people
respond to is that number rather than or
they should mathematically do which is
respond to what the number number
represents one of the pieces of advice
that you have for YouTube YouTube
thumbnail writing is to write at an
eighth grade level and then make it
like more dumb than that because as
people are scrolling through YouTube
every millisecond of attention that you
can potentially get from somebody is
very precious and if you can convey what
this particular video is about in a
quicker more easily understood way than
the next video you're going to improve
your click-through rate oh yeah no
lovely Point um I mean I think one of
the broad things we talked about last
time was this idea that
small bits of friction have an outsized
effect it might feel like oh surely I've
made such amazing videos people are
going to give me the benefit of doubt
they're going to work through some of
these small barriers that I put in the
way but most studies suggest that is is
not the case so if people wanted a
practical tip one of the things that
I've discovered reasonably recently is
there is a wonderful app called
Hemingway so it's completely free
you take your copy you put it into the
website or the app and it gives you a
reading age immediately and you can sit
there playing with your copy and it will
tell you in real time as you make those
tweaks as you make those adjustments how
you're dropping down the the reading no
way yeah it's brilliant it'll tell you
you've got too many use of the passive
you've got too many long sentences too
many complex sentences and it's lovely
because it reacts in real time so you
can see your score improving and I would
say in terms of copywriting you're
absolutely right on the simplest things
you can do do is pitch a much lower
reading age than you expect it will it
will help
extremeness aversion
ah extreme subversion so um lovely set
of studies from originally a psychology
called amosfersky so he was the pop
research partner for years and years of
Daniel Kahneman Conor went on to win the
Nobel Prize in 2002 unfortunately to
first get died by that stage and you
can't give a Nobel posthumously so he
probably would have won the Nobel if it
lived long enough
but back in 1993 he runs a a famous
study recruits group of people and shows
them two cameras so you've got this
basic and cheap camera let's say I can't
remember what it was 139 and then a
fancy expensive camera for say 200.
and he asked people which would you pick
which would you prefer and you get a
rough 50 50 split
he then gets another group of people
shows them those same two cameras
but he also offers this new group a
third camera for say 400 with loads of
bells and whistles loads of
functionality and
what he finds is that only a small
proportion of people is 21 of people I
think pick that really high-end camera
but what's of interest to us is the
proportion of people in those original
two cameras shifts dramatically it's no
no longer one-to-one it's now three to
one in favor of the fancy camera
now he calls this finding and it has
been repeated with beer popcorn coffee
all sorts of different products he calls
this idea extremist aversion he says one
of these quick rules of thumb that we
use to decide
um how to behave is to pick the middle
option we fear that the cheapest option
will be tacky and will look a bit mean
we fear that the most expensive option
will be over engineered and will look
like a show-off
so the the interesting thing here is you
can shift people's willingness to pay by
introducing a super expensive item that
you never expect anyone to purchase
so let's say you are selling a
subscription to your gym program and you
offer people well you can have a monthly
price or you can sign up for annual and
let's say as a gym you are going to
benefit by getting the loadable to sign
up for your annual run your monthly
offering what most people would do is
just think of well I'll reduce the
annual price I'll give people more
benefits but if you know about extremist
aversion what you would do is think well
let's offer a two-year subscription a
three-year subscription you don't expect
many people to sign up for that but it's
very presence makes the annual option
look better in comparison and it's that
comparative bit that is so important in
pricing
are you familiar with sub stack do you
subscribe to any sub stacks I don't know
what sub stack it's a Blog platform it's
kind of like what medium used to be but
okay yeah yeah it's very it's very very
good it's super super popular at the
moment and they have they are using
extremeness aversion they're using the
exact strategy that you're talking about
you can sign up monthly you can sign up
yearly and then in almost every single
person's or creators profile there is a
founding member
option and the founding member option is
usually the equivalent of maybe three or
four or five years so let's say it's
um ten dollars a month it's a hundred
dollars a year or it's 500 for the
founding member yeah the founding member
gets I I don't know commemorative pin or
something that's basically pointless and
and a logo but what you're actually
doing here is anchoring people to think
well
that that middle middle price is not so
bad I'll go for the I'll go for the
hundred dollars one so anchoring has to
be a key bias that extremist aversion is
is LinkedIn absolutely and there is a
lovely
um lesser known study by suckling
Liechtenstein that that suggests that
the way that most brands use Extreme as
a version could be improved on so
imagine I'm sure it's probably the same
as sub stack but most things Netflix
Spotify you go to their site and there's
the basic option the mid option the
premium option left to right the
suckling Liechtenstein experiment says
that is not the perfect approach what
you should do is show people the most
expensive option first
so their argument and it's based on a
lovely study and a fancy craft beer bar
in America uh their argument is it's the
first price that you see that is the
most powerful anchor so yes you want an
expensive thing to make everything else
look better value but it's the first
thing that people see that
set that expectation so if people need
read left to right you should go high
medium low rather than what most brands
do which is low medium that's the same
I'm pretty sure I learned this from you
on one of our last conversations the
same reason why restaurants should start
their menu with some incredibly
expensive platter
six person tasting menu yeah yeah 350
pounds which makes the overpriced
focaccia bread at the first start of the
aperitifes yeah into a sweat when you
see that 850 thing oh my God I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be bankrupt so by the time
you get to the other 10 pound for
capture you think wow phew yeah yeah
look at how brilliant value this for
catcher is the same thing goes for wines
as well right like just pitch something
nice and expensive at the top anchor
everything down off that have you ever
seen
is there such a thing as making that too
too big would it ever scare people away
no that's a very good point so
I think you've got to the the nub of
them out of there in the suddenly
Lichtenstein experiment it's it's
running a craft beer bottle so people
come and sit down and they're given this
menu of I think it's 13 beers either
they see the cheapest beer I think four
dollars at the top most expensive
ten dollars at the bottom or they see
the ten dollar beer at the top cheapest
at the bottom and what suckling
Lichtenstein find is there is a four
percent increase in average spend when
the most expensive beer is at the top
um now that's brilliant if you run a bar
or I think a restaurant because it
suggests you should definitely be making
sure the first thing people experience
is expensive but I think if someone has
gone to a bar they're not going to pick
up a menu see one item drop the menu and
walk out without lowering their eyes you
know a millimeter they're slightly
committed they've spent at least five or
ten minutes to get there
if you're on a website
you're probably not as committed there's
a greater risk of someone coming to the
website seeing a high price and bouncing
so if you run this test you've got to
monitor both
average spend and conversion rate
so I think you're right that there is a
danger that you take a finding in one
setting you use it elsewhere and you
don't see the results you expect so
e-commerce and bars are are different
things
but what I think so valuable about this
study is it at least suggests a test you
might never consider otherwise and the
brilliant thing with these tests is if
they work you run them forever massive
upside they don't work you run them for
a week turn them off limited downside so
absolutely agree there are situations in
which the experiment might not have the
same result if you change the context
and then secondly that's yeah it's a
really interesting point about could you
push this too far
I know there was a Italian restaurant in
Britain called Carluccio's and they
pushed it to ridiculous extremes they
had a Vespa for sale on the menu so
three thousand pound Vespa now I think
that's a brilliant way of using a
radical really expensive anchor because
you see that and you're not gonna
suddenly
fear that you're going to end up with a
really really expensive meal you're not
going to feel like these people are
exploiting you but you've put out this
massive number and you make comparative
everything else look a bit cheaper so I
think in that circumstance the way that
car Loop shows did it you could have a
really extreme number and not transgress
fairness norms however I know there is
an argument from negotiators that if you
try this on a one-to-one basis uh Chris
Foss talks about this more from
experience I think than experiment but
he says if you go into negotiation in
the pay review and you say I want a
million pounds well it's such a
ridiculous number that you are seen as
acting in bad faith and therefore you
discredit yourself so I kind of think
that I've always got that Chris Voss
voice in the back of my head uh when
you're thinking about these these
anchors so yeah don't probably push it
too far
I wonder whether there is something
going on here to do with the categories
of the products and which ones are
particularly susceptible to what we're
talking about I get the sense that it
would be more effective when you are
looking at a menu or a list of items
that are very easily comparable but if
Barker and Stonehouse were to put an
incredibly expensive lamp up top I
wonder how much that crosses over when
you're in there to shop for a sofa or
for a rug or for something else the same
thing goes I find it very difficult
um to gauge the quality off the price of
supplement brands for instance because
you go in and you go well they've got
this really expensive protein but I'm
not here for protein I'm here to buy a
new gym bag or I'm here to get whatever
um so I wonder whether the the breadth
of the product range allows that anchor
to almost decay in some way yeah I mean
that's I think that's a really
interesting hypothesis I think you're
right in the people are probably you
know there are so many numbers around us
this
people are going to create their own
mental comparison set so ideally you
want to be setting a
um a high anchor within that mental
comparison so I think that makes yeah
that that seems fair enough
I think there you're probably getting to
the degree of complexity where it gets
the stage of the experiments that exist
take you so far and then each individual
brand probably needs to be thinking well
how can I re-run these studies in my
particular store to see what works best
for me
denominator neglect
denominate neglect
um now I think I might sorry in my
um uh in my idiocy at the beginning I
think I've Blended together
um base rate neglect which was the ciao
hand lotion experiment and I think I
raced straight into denominator neglect
so when I was talking about jelly beans
I realized about halfway through I might
have been um
very similar though yeah yeah I mean
they they do they um I think it's that
underlying point of the naive reaction
to numbers which is key so you want to
think how can I it's got to be honest
how can I honestly quote the largest
possible
um discount so you know
uh base rate neglect you're talking
about uh maybe thinking about added
bonus rather than discount to nominate
and neglect well that's when you move to
areas like Gonzalez and the rule of
Android you had this thing about
stacking discounts in ascending order if
you're going to if anyone in the UK
that's ever shopped in TK Maxx I don't
know if they have TK Maxes over here in
America but that's the sort of store
where you would see 40 off plus 10 off
plus an extra five percent off yeah you
like I I don't have the computing power
to be able to work out what the price of
this item is well what people do is they
say Okay 40 10 5 that's
55 off but it's not actually because if
you take off 40 your 10 is then off a
smaller number and then your five is off
an even smaller number still so I'd have
to would have to go back and do the
maths and please set 17 attempts but you
end up it's actually like a 51 discount
so again it's stacking discounts is a
way of making people as you said
emotionally respond and feel like
they're getting a a better offering than
they perhaps are you said as well about
adjusting the font size to get people to
focus on either the sale price or on the
original price and you can sort of
adjust how much waiting people have
there yeah this is an interesting one I
think that this one from the the Coulter
Brothers
um what they show is they recruit a
group of people
and
half the people say see a original price
of a hundred pounds in small font and
then new price 60 pounds in big form
other people see original price 100
pounds in big form
uh new price 60 pounds in small font and
what they show is the second group the
people who see the end discounted price
in the smaller font they think there's
been a larger reduction in price so they
argue that people conflate
physical size of the number with what it
represents so here you want to be a bit
careful because it is a one-off study
so is it has it got the same probability
of working for your brand as something
like scarcity or social proof
um or fairness where they've read
meta-analyzes and hundreds upon hundreds
of studies in these areas probably not
but
another example of a potential
experiment that you can
apply to your pricing at no cost to
yourself
and in potentially increase your your
margins so I think that it's a really
interesting one as a
an Aries test that if you hadn't heard
of their study you might never ever
think of experimenting on it the need to
experiment ah well that that runs over
brilliantly
um so
what we've been discussing so far is
sometimes the results you will get from
a study will vary by context and
sometimes you will find a study that
sounds interesting but it's only ever
been one runs one run once now in those
scenarios
so if you're either applying a studying
a different place or there's not a huge
body of evidence for it you can't be
certain it will work so you need to set
up your own experiments as a brand as a
business to rerun the study but in your
category your specific brand your
specific circumstances
now if you're going to do that
you've firstly got a great opportunity
because all these studies I'm mentioning
are in the the public domain so you can
re-run the methodology quite easily just
with those few tweaks that we talked
about
and if you do them though what you've
got to be really careful of is how you
test these ideas so you don't want to be
directly asking consumers what motivates
them if you say to your consumers okay
well I'm thinking about say extremist
version I'm thinking about not just
offering you basic and premium I'm now
going to offer you basic premium super
premium would that change how you
behaved
your customer will properly laugh at you
swear at you they'll say well I'm not a
bloody idiot of course that wouldn't
affect me I will weigh up the amount
you're charging versus the benefits you
give me so if you're interested in
experimenting you cannot ask people
directly what you have to do is this
simple approach of
you know what we call a magnetic test
half the audience has seen one of the
offerings so that's basic versus premium
half of the audience is a basic premium
super premium and if you split things
out in that way if you get a
representative sample you give them
randomize them into one of these two
groups you keep everything in the two
settings the same apart from one
variable any difference in performance
any difference in people's reaction to
those offerings you could attribute back
to that single change variable
so
yes you need to experiment but make sure
the way that you experiment is
sophisticated enough in that you don't
take people's claims at face value okay
so don't rely on stated preferences wait
for the revealed ones and monadic is
that just change one variable don't [__]
about with anything else it yeah it's
it's uh it's it's a slightly pompous way
that I think that that's the danger with
academics that's a dangerous
psychologist hey take a basic principle
they give it a fancy name and they
confuse the hell out of people so all
men addict means I think monad is kind
of Greek for one or something people are
not comparing side by side you're
randomizing people into groups and then
you as the with the bird's eye view you
the experimenter give both those groups
the reasonably same offering but you
change one variable between the two
groups and yeah absolutely any
difference in performance attributes
that that single change variable I
really enjoyed the story that you told
you had seven biases that Ogilvy tested
I think it was maybe
charity yeah yeah yeah that's yeah yeah
absolutely oh so that's yeah the lovely
example so um
what Ogilvy change to or over the
console I think they're called now is
they create an annual report and one of
the wonderful things they do is they
include things that didn't work as well
as things that that did
and they ran a test for Christian Aid I
think it was in 2018. so 1.2 million
envelopes go out for Christian Aid and
they put a little envelope through your
door which basically asks you to
donate money into it you put money into
the envelope and then they'll come
around say a few days later and collect
it they tested seven different
messages so some of those envelopes that
went through people's door might have
said you know please donate the
government will add on another donation
on top gift aid some of the messages
said for example you've only got one
week to donate they're trying to move
people to action
exactly exactly and then another one of
those seven was using heavier more
expensive paper you know thicker paper
stop for the envelope
now that thicker paper
generated twice the level of donations I
think it was 39 Pence on average per
person versus 18 Pence for the gift aid
offering I don't think many people would
predict that
it might be easy to post-rationalize
afterwards you could say okay well it's
all about costly signaling you subtly
infer that people are a bit mean if they
only give a pound and it makes them want
to stick a bit more money into they
don't feel guilty themselves you know
very easy to post-rationalize it but to
say that was going to happen beforehand
I think is is unlikely so to me it's a
lovely example firstly of a company
admitting what worked as well as what
didn't and then secondly showing them
you know it's often very hard you know
people are complex it's very hard to
know will work so if you're in a complex
situation you should be running uh
experiments to prove something like
these ideas that I'm I'm saying work in
generality they really sort of spread
the strategies there as well one of them
was there was a special stamp that
looked like it had been hand stamped and
they said this has been delivered and
and prepared by hand which was what's
that labor illusion yeah so people call
Labor illusion illusion of effort yeah I
mean that that's often
um works very well you know Karma if we
talked about that last time but there's
a lovely study by Morales I think at the
University of Southern California where
she goes out and recruits people and
um gives them a list of say 10 houses
that meets their their requirements
some people are told that the estate
agent generated this list automatically
with a computer in an hour others are
told the state agent took nine hours and
they created the list manually
when people rate the quality of this day
agent afterwards
the group who here the estate agent went
to that extra effort they rate the
estate agent their ability at 36 percent
higher than the other group oh we did no
we did we did talk about this we talked
about it in um
uh the example was sky scanner and it
was oh yeah loading bar of Skyscanner
which is yeah yeah yeah technologically
totally arbitrary and exclusively
performative yes absolutely we might
have to talk about dice as well they're
my favorite example they talk about the
5127 prototypes they they got went
through to create the vacuumless bag now
you could argue well doesn't bloody
matter how many
failures there were what matters is how
high quality the final product is but
what Morales would say is look does it
matter if it should logically be
ineffective well behavioral scientists
are interested in what does have an
effect and people use efforts expended
as an easy way of making a decision
about the the quality of a product okay
so you would normally expect yeah that
emphasis of you know hand delivered uh
efforts going uh in in into collect
money to have an impact so you know the
fact it doesn't I think is something
that it's very good that this agency
admits uh occurred now if you don't want
people just to talk about their
successes we can learn just as much from
people's failures well you know looking
at the changes in donation that those
people had coming back it was 50 of them
were below the control or a good chunk
of them were below the control so there
was some things I think the scarcity
which most people that come from an
internet marketing world this is a
one-time offer the countdown timer
begins as you hit the page you have 45
minutes to claim this once in a lifetime
deal but when you said Christian Aid
needs all donations by the end of the
week what you actually saw was a
decrease compared to the control so yeah
you know and who would have guessed that
especially coming from a world that's
bereft of absolutely and if someone
Works in e-commerce they're probably
right to think that for their own brand
there's a lovely
um huge comparative study run by
swarbrick Jones I think they look like 2
600 e-commerce studies a lot of them in
travel and there's 28 different levers
that are used across these different
campaigns and they rank the various
different biases or levers on their
average sales effect and of the 28 they
look at the most effective overall is
volume scarcity there aren't many of
these hotel rooms left next is social
proof lots of people have bought this
type of hotel room third is what I would
call time scarcity what they call
urgency you haven't got long to act
so you're absolutely right for
e-commerce people I think scarcity is
probably one of the first biases time or
volume that you would think about
testing for your product
but I guess going back to that point we
made earlier around context is important
what you're probably starting to see
here is well
commercial and charity what works for
the two you know they're they're varied
enough that maybe you can't translate
some of the findings from commercial
settings into charity and vice versa I'm
thinking about my booking.com experience
which I use pretty regularly and I'm
thinking uh X many people have booked
this room today uh like hurry these
rooms are going fast there's only this
many left that we've got in our
allocation and all this stuff so it's
every single Bing there's taking all of
the boxes that you've spoken about there
so the next one which I think is very
important and it's important not only
for marketing but I think for personal
life too which is framing oh yeah yeah
very good one um so it's essentially the
idea that the same fact can have a
market Leaf to different effects
dependent on the the language that's
used
so the study that I discussed is a 1974
one from Loftus and Palmer uh the
University of Washington and they play a
video and you can get this if you people
Google
um Loftus and Palmer experimental video
car crash you will see a 15 second video
of two cars crashing into each other so
have a look at that and then what the
psychologist did was get a large group
of people
and they said to some people how fast
those cars going were they smashed
together
other people how fast those cars going
when they contacted other people how
fast were they going when they collided
so are you six or seven different words
and then they asked people to estimate
the speed of the two cars in miles per
hour and when the group who heard the
word smashed
when they estimate the speed they think
it's 40 miles 0.8 per hour
the group that heard the verb contacted
they think it's 31.8 miles per hour so
even though everyone is seeing exactly
the same footage there is a variance of
27 in terms of their speed estimate
now the psychologists were interested in
um police witness statements how people
could be influenced by a skilled
interviewer and so they were kind of
concerned with how a
a dubious
police person could manipulate findings
but I think if you're in marketing what
you can take from this is the language
that they use to sell your products can
be varied to huge impact so for example
one of my favorite studies that isn't
very well known is one from a Texan
cycle or a University of Texas
psychologist called Peterson
and he gets a large group of people
shows them an e-commerce site and for
every purchaser one of the items they're
trying to buy just isn't there
now sometimes on the site it's labeled
as unavailable some people see out of
stock other people see sold out
when he questions those groups as to how
irritate they are with the website he
sees a swing of 15 with the people who
see unavailable being the most irritated
people who see sold out the least
irritated
now everyone is is essentially like the
Lotus and Palmer study they are
experiencing the same thing on an
objective level it's just the language
that's used to describe that situation
varies and if the website emphasizes
unavailable they're emphasizing their
logistical attitude if the website
emphasizes sold out they're emphasizing
how popular this product is uh they're
harnessing social proof
so the argument here is people do not
experience events they experience the
um the description of events and if you
just change that description you can
radically change people's reaction to
the same situation
one of my favorite examples of this was
from Sam Harris and he says that
everybody knows what it's like to finish
a workout you are sweating and panting
on the floor and you've got the taste of
metal in the back of your throat and
your heart and your heart rate's through
the roof this is a situation which oddly
despite being kind of objectively
uncomfortable at the time is actually
oddly enjoyable exclusively because of
the framing that you place around it now
if you were to spontaneously feel that
while you were sat in traffic on your
way to work yeah yeah yeah ring the
hospital you would think that there is
something terrible with me so our story
of what we tell ourselves around an
experience very much is the determinant
of the experience as well like the story
that we tell ourselves largely
influences what the experience feels
like to us yeah so that that's a I've
not thought about it that way that's a
lovely exam never really often don't
think about these uh experiments in a
personal setting I'm always think about
them from a commercial setting but I um
I came back from a stanky once and the
flight land very badly and I'd always
been not particularly keen on flying but
that freaked me out and I developed a
fear of flying so I'd have to fly for
work yet I spent the entire flight
thinking what would it be like to fall
for five minutes from this plane that's
bound to um explode in the air now I
tried all sorts of things to distract
myself you know having a drink
um getting into a book doing a crossword
whatever it was all these different
things to try and get over this none of
them worked the thing that worked was
listening to heavy metal rap music
anything that has a you know a
adrenaline fuel reaction in normality so
I'd listen to it as we were taking off
and I think it over time changed my
response from thinking this is a signal
that my adrenaline signal this is a very
dangerous situation we're gonna die to
the adrenaline flooding my body well
that's just how I normally react to this
particular song oh wow so I'd never put
the two and two together but I think
you're actually right that's an example
of reframing exactly the same decision
by a different lens on it yeah you'd
you'd used
this isn't like a cue that people would
play car music in order to be calm this
is a cue from your body I'm full of
adrenaline so I will play music which is
associated with adrenaline that's funny
yeah so I always listen to exactly the
same song I'm not particularly into rap
but what is it I have a workout playlist
and one of them is um Kanye West um uh
school spirit so it's something he's
canceled now okay well I can't talk
I know you can still listen to him you
just can't can't take his views on the
Jews too seriously well yes I use music
so you there was another thing to do
with
um
and everybody's aware of this when you
buy mints or ground beef as it's called
out here do you want to call it 75 lean
or 25 fat
framing yeah yeah absolutely so there's
a I think that is a Levin study I might
get the name wrong but essentially it's
describing the same situation but if you
say 75 lean people will think the meat
will be tastier uh they think it'll be
less greasy if you emphasize 25 in fact
by drawing people's attention to that
particular element you get a very
different different reaction
um so you you also had the thing about
um using the benefit of using nouns
rather than verbs
oh yes so there is the idea that
if you remind people that they are a
voter
they're more likely to follow through
and and vote on the actual election day
then if you say to them will you vote so
will you be a vote they agree yeah will
you vote and they agree they are more
likely to follow through if they have
described themselves as a voter probably
because the voter that noun describes
who we are you know it's part of our
identity nature if you're just referring
to an action that's something that's
fleeting and not particularly
hypocritical
so yeah that's the idea so so we've
tried yeah
so we've tried to do um we've tried to
apply this commercially and I haven't
seen any results yet but reminding
people that they had been a subscriber
to a magazine and therefore should renew
rather than saying to people
um you know you want subscribed you
should renew so yeah I haven't got any
data back on that but that that's I
think it's something that could probably
be applied a bit a bit more
that's really interesting I wonder how
you get somebody from not being a thing
to being a thing my point being that
what we're talking about here is the
noun allows somebody to have that
identity become attached and what you're
looking to do is for what the identity
becomes attached to to be the action
that you want them to take if you want
people to vote you tell them that they
are a voter but if there was a world in
which it was really difficult to be a
voter or the only people that voted were
people that earned over a hundred
thousand dollars
I wonder how you get someone to believe
in the new noun identity if they don't
do you know what I mean yeah that's a
very good point um I mean the tactic I
think we might have talked about this
last time one tactic in this area is
What's called the foot in the door
technique which is if you want people to
adopt a new Behavior
try and make the first request
ridiculously easy so there's a 1966
study where sometimes the experimenters
Friedman Fraser asks people to put a
giant sign saying drive carefully in
their front garden and no barely anyone
does it other times they do a two-step
process where first of all they are
supposed to put up a tiny little sticker
saying drive carefully loads of people
do it uh the cycle will just leave wait
two weeks and then they come up with a
giant sign
and in that second scenario three or
four times more people put up the big
sign and their argument is well you make
the first request really easy so people
feel like they have to do it because it
would be churlish not to you know such
an important thing as Road Safety once
they've put up that sign now you can
then use that
um and the principle of consistency once
they've put up the sign you then
go back with your genuine ask and people
will remember their past Behavior
they'll want to be consistent with that
past Behavior they'll think themselves
off put up the sticker and must be
interested in Road Safety to be
consistent with that I better put up the
giant sign so I wonder if that if you
want to kick start this identity
start small would be it would be the big
thing ironically yeah fairness
oh yes this is one of the most
interesting areas I think when I was
researching the book
um and it's the idea that
people's reaction even in commercial
situations is remarkably driven by
fairness we're not just interested in a
good deal in an absolute sense we are
interested in being treated fairly
compared to others
so the study that that caught my eye was
I think it's a 1996 that it's quite an
old study it is with students so you
know take it with the picture soul but
it's a blouse and Baseline study
and when people arrive for the first day
at campus they are asked whether they
would help the psychologist the next day
with a
um an experiment they can have to turn
up the psychologists lab do 40 minutes
of math puzzles and they will be paid
seven dollars now the people who are
after that 72 of them agree to take part
next group of people
um
they are given the same basic request
come to our lab tomorrow do 40 minutes
of maths puzzles but this group are told
you will be paid eight dollars
however they then follow up with a
little white lie they are then told that
um other people earlier were paid ten
dollars but unfortunately they've spent
all their cash and they can only offer
it now
now in that scenario there is a 25 drop
in what people are prepared
to uh to accept so you get 54 of people
agreeing to take part
now this is fascinating because what a
classical Economist would say is well it
doesn't matter what other people are
paid or you should focus on is whether
or not eight dollars is worth 40 minutes
of your time
so you should have this increase but if
you think about the principle of
fairness people are enraged by this idea
that others have got a a better deal
now that study I think is fascinating
because you could apply this in big and
small ways if you're a brand
you can apply in a big strategic way and
think how do I reframe my competition as
treating their customers unfairly and if
you can do that you can tap into this
pool of anger that will motivate people
to want to switch come to your brand
or if we're getting super tactical you
could apply this on your e-commerce site
so think about what virtually every
e-commerce site does now you're shopping
for a pair of trainers you've picked
these trainers uh 100 you love them they
look amazing you're completely happy you
put them in your basket you go to
checkout and then above the checkout
button what is there normally normally
there is a giant box you know throbbing
giant white box that says you know add
your discount code
now that transgress fairness Norm is
essentially what you've done there is
told your customer you told these people
who are completely happy to hand over
the money that other people are getting
a better deal that will enragement and
they will go off and look for a discount
code most of them will probably probably
never come back
so yeah fairness I think is a
interesting area that too many Brands
ignore too many Brands think that people
are cold calculating machines but
actually an awful lot of behavior is
driven by you know not the absolute
benefit of the offer it's am I get
relatively getting good deal compared to
other people
Shopify interestingly if you're on
mobile it's not the same if you're on
desktop but I would guess that probably
at least 50 maybe 70 or more of shopping
is done on Shopify and mobile
yeah their discount
field is hidden behind a drop down
toggle yeah great yeah yeah that's
that's a really nice idea because I
think what that's working on and I think
Uber do something similar with like a
um you know if you've got a promo code
it's a very recessive little link you
can add and I think they're working on
the principle that people who have a
code will be really looking for the way
to put it people who haven't won so
that's one by default by default given
the fact that probably fewer people will
be shopping with a code than without a
code why defaults to make the code and
this big advert that you're paying more
than you probably should do and more
than other people potentially are yes
yeah but I think absolutely you could
have a um you could only show the
discount box for example for people
you've driven there fire Affiliates uh
you could put up your prices by a
percent and then populate the box with a
one percent off code and then anyone
else who has an actual code could
overwrite it you know there's loads of
different ways did you see um talking
about fairness I think this has stopped
over the last few years but there was a
period especially when Black Friday
first became big in the UK where fast
fashion companies and jewelry companies
were slowly creep the price of their
product up throughout October into
November or they would just switch it
over one week and then the discount and
people were using way back machine and
internet archive and stuff to go back
and look at what the old price of this
product was what they realized was that
with the discount the price of the
product was the same as it was when you
could have purchased it at the start of
October yes so I mean I think there is
an opportunity there potentially for
competitor Brands to shine a light on
that
um
I think there is also
a self-interested doubt that you should
have at the back of your mind about some
of these tactics which is the difference
in the short and the long term in the
short term you will generate extra cash
by some slightly nefarious tactics the
danger you have is p if people ever feel
they have been manipulated too far then
you get this this kind of um uh
retribution
so you've got always got a bit of a
balance of how much you should push some
of these pricing tactics and there's a
lovely idea from I think it said
American floss called John Rawls who
talks about the things the publicity
principle and he basically talks about
morality as
if someone knew you're applying this
tactic
would they be angry with you and if they
are then it should set off some alarm
Bells at least you can should consider
whether it's worth doing you know it's a
debate I think of the the Richard daler
goes back and forth on the beginning of
his book Nudge are you familiar with
good Hearts law
yes I uh isn't it something along the
lines of once a metric is used as a
Target that metric loses all validity
correct yeah so
um you know it yeah it's when a
let's say that your outcome that you
wanted to get
um that the metric that you were
optimizing for was email subscribers so
you say I want as many email subscribers
as possible so that's a Target what
you're actually looking for the outcome
that you're looking for is something
more like I want lots of people that
care about what I say to be interested
and receiving my emails in a warm and
welcoming way on a weekly basis like
that's what you're actually optimizing
for but the measure that you're using is
the outcome proxy is email subscribers
but if you start to optimize exclusively
for that what you could see is a world
in which you said sign up to my mailing
list and every person that does will be
given a million pounds
a free pair of shoes and when people
sign up and they find out that that
isn't the promise that they're going to
get on the other side of that you go
well look I achieved the target which
was get lots of email subscribers but it
wasn't the actual outcome that I was
looking for the measure ceases to be a
good Target
yes if there is a sliver of difference
between what you're incentivizing and
what you actually want you generate some
pretty dangerous
um repercussions uh I think you had an
apology is it getting easy I don't know
how to pronounce it it's really easy
yeah easy Sneezy sorry uh wonderful book
mixed signals and he talks there's a
there's a chapter in the middle and it's
a wonderful
um coverage of some
responses to ill-set incentives so one
of them he talks about I think it might
have been British archaeologists in in
China where they this is not a 19th
century they reward
um peasants there for bringing them
pieces of fossil and they get a set
amount of cash per piece
so what happens is those people are you
know very uh uh interested in maximizing
their income so rather than bring a
complete fossil bone they find those
fossil bones They smash them into 20
pieces then they take each piece uh one
at a time to the the archaeologist to
maximize their their income so yeah
you've got to be very careful about uh
what incentive you set talking about
fairness covered toilet roll prices in
the UK oh yes so
um gosh that was a study I ran back uh
in the midst of covid when people were
hoarding toilet roll and what I asked
was I set people a little thought
experiment I said imagine your local
supermarket was charging a pound for
toilet roll they've put up the price to
say two pounds I can't remember what it
was during that shortage do you think
this is fair and it was a phenomenal
proportion of people who said it was
very unfair or unfair it was saying of
the order of like 90 percent
most economists would say this is just a
reaction of supply and demand but people
don't treat prices in that manner they
feel that the exploitation of a surge in
demand with excess pricing is unfair and
there's a danger that they will
punish that that that that that supplier
you also spoke about how you could use
righteous indignation to compel people
to do stuff
yes I kind of think this is something
that isn't really used enough I'm I'm
interested in fairness because
we've talked about the Blount basement
study now people would rather have a
smaller fee that everyone's getting than
a large fee but let Which is less than
than others now you also see that in
animals there is an amazing video online
I would strongly recommend people Google
afterwards if you put in France dewal
capture monkeys fairness video what you
will see is a pair of monkeys happily
performing all sorts of tasks for a
slice of cucumber
but if one of those monkeys is paid in
grapes which they rate as a better treat
and one is paid in cucumber the monkey
that is now being paid in cucumber will
lose their rag they will not perform for
this uh this this payment so again it's
it's a bias that you can see in humans
and something we shared a common
ancestor with three million years ago
when you see these drives of behavior
straddling the species you'll know
you're on so powerful so if I was a
brand I would look at ways of reframing
my competition as behaving unfairly so
if I was launching a
um a competitive taxi brand to Uber
surge pricing I think is their Achilles
seal uh most banks if I was trying to
compete with them if I was new fintech
startup I would be talking about uh or
reaching people when they have just been
hit by a fine they've gone you know two
pounds over their overdraft limit
they've just been hit with the 20 pound
fine that's a rare moment when people
are so enraged they're probably open to
to switching so how do you reframe what
your
um competition are doing as a as a
fairness transgression very nice freedom
of choice
hmm so this is an interesting area
there's um and my pronunciation is isn't
very good I was always horrendous at
languages at school so uh it is a French
psychologist I think called The Game and
he came up with an idea called the but
you are free principle
so one of many bizarre psychology
experiments where it involves the
psychologist dressing up as a beggar uh
there's another one by a guy called
Santos called the um the peak effect all
around how surprising requests generate
more num more donations but on this one
again goes up to people at a or near a
bus stop and he says can you give me
some coins so I can get a bus
and I think it's 10 of people give him
some coins
next group of people who goes up exactly
the same request to begin with but then
at the end he says but you are free to
accept or refuse
and the proportion of people who give
them money jumps to I think 48
. that's a huge swinging Behavior
what's so interesting is of course
everyone in both of those settings
always had the ability to say no all
that's changed is the requester has
drawn attention
to the other person's ability to say no
so the argument here is one of the
things that we love is to retain a sense
of agency a sense of control in the
situation so if you are trying to
persuade someone to take out a
subscription
to give you a rise what you should be
doing is drawing their attention to the
fact they can say no what could gain
study suggests is that will increase the
probability slightly paradoxly of them
agreeing to your demands
so you want to involve people
in the decision process in a way yes but
I think remind them of their right to
say no so it's not just
um involving them I think it's give
reminding their sense of control uh it
is the key thing and of course uh you
know situations with Beggars are a
little bit bizarre that five-fold
increase is a very very large one so
it's not just that situation where this
but you're free principle Works
um I think it was Carpenter who ran a
analysis about 15 studies I think where
he looked at lots of different people
had run experiments where they had
emphasized the other person's freedom to
refuse and there is a consistent
increase in compliance now it might not
be as high as the gate and study but
it's a consistent consistency very
reliable what so
something else that seems to make sense
here is if you were overly assertive
when communicating with customers and
there was a uh place in Austin a
recovery uh Center that had some
internal strife and it it was going to
change and all of the management was
going to drop and they also decided to
along with that so there was sort of a
how would you say a foundation a
baseline of ambient sort of discontent
because there was some social murmurings
in gossip about what was going on behind
the scenes and then one
Saturday
morning every single member of this
Recovery Place got an email that said
prices are going up and it was going up
by maybe 2X or two and a half X and you
will be billed and the new prices kick
in in 48 hours reply if you want to if
you if you want to cancel or something
like that and the number of people that
I know who were really really sort of
upset put off by that and one one of the
main things that happened there was it
was the kind of language that was used
it was basically like prices going up uh
like it Olympic you know if you reply if
you want to cancel type thing and that
native language I think didn't do them
very many things yeah I mean it seems
like they've got a Kind of Perfect Storm
of problems there I think the one thing
they did a couple of other things they
did they said that the price rise was
going to be immediate there's a lovely
set of studies
um by people like Liam Delaney at the
universe he was the University of
Sterling into What's called the present
preference bias so I think in one of his
his studies says to people do you want
to pay me 13 pounds now or 16 pounds in
a month's time and that's of the order
of 60 of people would rather pay the
larger amount in a month's time now if
you turn that into a monthly interest
rate I think it's 23 if you turn it into
an annualized interest rate some it's
over a thousand percent a year it's a
phenomenal interest rate but people
would prefer to pay it than give over
the money in that instant so what he
argues is what he calls present
preference bias we overweight pleasure
and the pain in the now and we discount
Pleasure and Pain in the future far far
too much so if I was going to push that
price rise through I would give people
loads of notice and tell them it's
happening in two or three months time
because spending an extra 10 pounds a
month in that distant time period won't
affect me knowing I've got hand over 10
pounds tomorrow that's aggravating so
give me the the justification for
Charming versus cajoling uh an audience
member it seems like charm is always
going to work
yeah I mean they were always with all
these there are a few nuances one of the
interesting ones is um
the original kind of experiments are far
earlier than uh gagane was a guy called
brem I think it's Jack brem and he came
up with an idea called reactants so
um uh it's the argument if you feel your
freedom is being curtailed you can often
push out against this and
the one of the early studies was by a
guy called pennebaker at the University
of Texas and and um so he puts up signs
in a men's washroom that's either says
please don't graffiti or do not graffiti
exclamation mark exclamation mark and he
sees I think of the order of twice the
amount of graffiti on the authoritarian
side
but what's interesting so that's the
same basic finding as you know you're
discussing we've got with again that if
you're overly authoritarian it can
backfire but one of the interesting
nuances is the extent of that backfire
effect depended on the authority level
of the communicator so if the sign was
positioned as coming from the head of
security
it really aggravate people if the sign
came from the groundsman it didn't have
much of a negative reaction in the in
the authoritarian manner so the point
being here is reactance is far more
likely to occur if the message comes
from someone in a position of power
so if you are doing peer-to-peer
Communications of equal people it might
not be too much of an issue if it is a
letter coming from the tax office and
they are
um
behaving authoritarily it's much more
likely to create this this negative
reaction so thinking about who the
message comes from
uh is it is an important one I'm trying
to work out why this effect would exist
you know fairness makes a lot of sense
it's reciprocal altruism it's not being
taken for a ride we could see how that
would be adaptive
having I don't know this this pushback
against a tyrannical leader almost even
if the tyrannical leader happens to be a
badly worded poster or a poor email or
48 hours ago it's about a price rise
yeah
um I find it fascinating that it seems
like embedded in our psychology is a way
that we react to the local ecology in
terms of how tyrannical it is uh how
authoritarian it is it's mediated by the
person that is giving that request in a
way which also suggests that we have
some kind of softness bias toward people
that are lower down the totem pole I
think the implications of this are
really interesting yeah I I that's an
interesting question about why it
happens and I wonder if you often look
to some of these biases is could there
be an evolutionary explanation
and maybe it's a sense of well if we
fear that we are losing control that you
know reduces our life chances
potentially if if someone else is in
charge they're probably going to look
after themselves rather than us maybe
maybe we are queued up to respond in
that way but that's slightly speculative
there is uh some good evidence that
talks about two different types of
leaders that would have happened
ancestrally so one that rises due to
prestige and another Rises due to
dominance the one that rises due to
dominance is preferred during times of
warfare times of strife chaos because
you need the strong no-nonsense we are
going to go and do this we charge
forward you don't listen to anybody else
like let's just get this done those
leaders don't perform anywhere near as
well during times of Peace in fact
they're often killed homicide was the
one of the most common forms of death
from within the tribe not from outside
of the tribe it was within homicide and
um yeah I wonder whether there's
I don't know would we have been at war
or at peace most of the time ancestrally
perhaps we would have been in times of
Peace which means that we have almost
this kind of
um uh authoritarian radar or like a
tyranist radar that means oh if the way
that I feel at the moment is if I'm in a
bathroom and I'm just trying to take a
piss in in peace yeah this isn't the
environment in which I will respond
particularly well to someone that is
using dominance to try and get me to do
something
um that's interesting so the next one
which I learned from Rory Sutherland the
first time actually was The Red Sneakers
effect
yeah
um so a lovely set of studies from
Francesca Gino at the the Harvard
Business School and the basic idea is
if we see people breaking conventions we
assume they are higher status so my
favorite part of her study is a pilot
study she did so when she's testing out
the basic idea she goes out to academic
conferences
and this is early 2000s and the norm of
behavior at these conferences the
convention is you stress smartly so if
you're a bloke you'd be expected to wear
a shirt jacket
so as people arrive at the conference
she monitors uh their Smart's address
and she notes it down she then goes and
finds those people and says them how
many Publications you got how many uh
citations have you got so citation is
one review of your one mention of your
work your academic work in a peer review
paper so more citations the more
successful you're you know crude metric
but you're pretty accurate
when she crosses the two bits of data
she sees a very clear inverse
correlation so the super successful
academics you know the people who go and
talk shows uh you know write
newspaper columns they're the ones who
are most likely to be breaking the
convention and dressing really scruffily
whereas if you go down to the other end
the people with barely any citations the
people who've barely published anything
you know people haven't got tenure
people are just starting out in their
career they are much much more likely to
abide by the conventions
now Geno's argument is that you need
status to break a convention so imagine
a situation in which
um you're at work the CEO turns up
wearing Bermuda shorts well in that
scenario no one is going to send that
person home no one's going to criticize
them but if the intern does it they get
sent home they get pillared
so what Geno argues is you need a degree
of Social Capital to to afford or to be
able to break intervention you can
ignore some of the punishments
and what or they won't be applied to you
and what she says is that people and
this is what our latest studies show is
people are remarkably well achieved this
so we see people breaking inventions we
assume they must be higher status so I
love this because
many advertisers have heard the argument
that if you behave distinctively you're
more likely to be noticed
what genoads is another layer which is
if you behave distinctively if you break
convention you're more likely to be seen
as high higher status too so it's a bit
more kind of new news to most brands to
most businesses to most communicators
how would you apply this
so I think for most brands they're an
awful lot of conventions in their
category if you think about how watch
ads behave how perfumes how car has
behave most of them
uh abide by the same conventions you
know think about a press ad for a car at
nine times out of ten it shows a
beautiful mountain of sea in bendy Road
and then there's the the car in a kind
of profile shop
what Geno would say is if you
unthinkingly just repeat this convention
in your advertising you'll be seen as
low status what you should do is
think of your category think of all the
different conventions split those
conventions into two groups some of
which are there for a very good reason
leave those well alone others are just
there for tradition's sake if you break
those conventions
firstly the Von rest office effect says
you'll be noticed but also the red
stickers effect says you're likely to be
um believed to be higher status admired
more and this is mediated at least a
little bit by the
um existing awareness the positioning of
the brand if yeah Kia decides to break
convention it's different to if Audi
decides to break convention yeah
absolutely so yeah you're absolutely
right with all these studies there are
nuances and and Gino looks a few I think
one of them is
you need to be or the audience needs to
know you're breaking this on purpose if
they think you're breaking a convention
through ignorance it can backfire and
then secondly yes if someone is already
perceived Behind status and they break
invention the rewards are much much
greater
if you get down to someone who is
perceived or ready to be low status
and Daybreak convention it can again
backfire so yeah there is a variance on
those two those two criteria the halo
effect
uh the halo effect so this is an
interesting one it's essentially the
idea that
people's do not evaluate each element of
another person discreetly
if they feel that someone is Superior in
one respect it ripples out to all their
other attributes so the classic study
well there are Classics those going back
to the 1920s but the one I really liked
the 1977 study by Nisbet recruits 118
people and they all see a video of a
Belgian academic giving a lecture
now half the people see a video same
content but the academics a little rude
and comes across as a bit cold
the other half of people see the
academic uh being more friendly and warm
now as you'd expect when the two groups
rate the likability of academic the
group who see the warm friendly academic
rates them as 72 more likely so you just
as you expect you behave in a nice way
you're more likable
what's interesting though is Nisbet also
asks about loads of other attributes of
the the lecturer you know what's their
appearance like how irritates their
accent and he finds the when the
lecturer was behaving in that friendly
manner people are twice as likely to
enjoy the acts and think that he's good
looking as in the other scenarios
behaving like a bit of an idiot so the
argument is here if you have one
dominant
uh positive or negative characteristic
that will affect how your other
unrelated characteristics are are
interpreted
so what's interesting here is if you are
a business and you're trying to
communicate how amazing you are how
trustworthy you want to be how high
quality you are you don't have to just
communicate those things you could pick
another area which is easier to impress
people on and then the expectation with
all of your attributes and your metrics
would would improve so it's almost a
different way of thinking about what you
should communicate don't necessarily
communicate what matters communicate
what is easy to impress people on
and I think one area here for Brands is
think about well coming across as witty
and Charming you could actually do that
in advert you can actually be funny
how you convince someone you are
trustworthy or high quality well that's
a nebulous thing that it's harder to do
in an advert so work with the
limitations of the kind of communication
medium uh and try and emphasize the
metric that you can move not necessarily
the metric you think matters that's very
interesting I like the fact that um with
the halo effect which in pop psychology
is traditionally to do with pretty
privilege basically that you have good
looking people and everybody produces
everything that they do is better what
you're saying here is that there are a
number of different vectors upon which
you could win if you were Charming if
you were funny if you were polite if you
were good looking if you were tall if
you were reputable if you were whatever
whatever like educated well-informed so
on and so forth
you can use whichever of these you can
win at to trickle down and try and
Cascade all the rest of them and I would
imagine as well that there are some that
are longer levers than others I would
imagine wit humor personability sort of
charm uh politeness pleasantness
generally from an interpersonal
perspective are going to be things that
will trickle Downstream uh more
effectively because they're much more
Universal
yeah I mean from a Communications
perspective I think
and this is where it's we're going to
move into speculative territory so it
would be interesting in challenges on
this one but I wonder if something like
behaving wittily you you can do that in
an advert you can make a joke
you don't just have to claim that you're
funny the problem with when it comes to
attributes like
trustworthiness or premiumness it's very
hard to absolutely demonstrate you have
to make a a claim and the problem with
claims is why would anyone believe them
because if you are low quality or high
quality you're both going to say you're
amazing quality you know a claim is is
completely empty much more powerful to
focus on things that can be demonstrated
rather than claims and I wonder if
that's why you're right on on areas like
wit it's something you can demonstrate
rather than just State what about being
too clever it must be such a thing as
that
that's interesting so I mean the Wonder
the the closest study I've seen there is
the the platform effect the original
1966 study by Elliot Aronson so he
recruits a uh a colleague of his taking
part in a quiz
and the guy is given secretly the
questions and the answers by Aaronson so
does amazingly well I think gets 90 or
92 of the questions right wins the quiz
by Miles
now when people are played a recording
of that Amazing Quiz performance he and
they're asked how much they like the
conquest contestant the listeners give a
so-so rating
next group of people they're played the
same recording of the Amazing Quiz
performance but there is an additional
30 seconds and in the final moments the
quiz the contestant makes a [__] up he
spills a cup of coffee down himself
in that scenario the listeners who get
that recording rate the contestant
there's 40 or 45 more appealing
so I think you're right there it can be
this thing of perfection can be
irritating if someone comes across as
this amazing
um genius well uh you know our reaction
is maybe to hate them somewhat because
we feel worse in comparison
if they spill a cup of coffee themselves
they're no longer seen as maybe quite so
much of a threat and therefore they can
come across as a bit more appealing so I
think there is
there might be yeah I think there is
something in what you say
um in the world of online content
creation there's a number of people who
are really struggling at the moment
because they never show vulnerability
people know that they've got
vulnerability people know that they
their self-righteousness or the fact
that they are you know unperturbed by
whatever criticisms come from the
internet and a lot of these people are
like quite worthy of criticism
but that has galvanized huge Reddit
threads there's hundreds of thousands of
people in certain sub corners of the
internet that basically are trying to
find the vector on which they can
finally get this person to show that
something is actually bothering them and
I think that it's almost that sort of
two perfect concern that we've got here
yeah if someone never shows any
um weakness vulnerability we become
skeptical of that because we see it for
ourselves the you know first off we're
skeptical because we think everybody has
this secondly we are
um untrusting of them because we presume
that they must be hiding what it is
they've got behind it thirdly we would
say well I'm going to continue to poke
and poke and poke because this is a fun
game to see how much this person can
take before they do end up breaking uh
yeah it kind of creates a perfect storm
to Galvanize people to try and take
someone down I've seen this multiple
times and it's basically the same
formula yeah I think
um there's a I think you're absolutely
right there is a um there's a lovely
study by Northwestern University where
they look at likelihood to purchase
products after reading a product review
so it's all
numeric product reviews zero to five
five being perfect zero being crap and
what they show is as the review gets
better people become more like to
purchase they look at a hundred thousand
different
um you know offerings that's a huge
sample
but what they find for every of the 2025
categories that they look at for every
every one of those categories the
highest rate of purchases is not a five
out of five reviews it's uh somewhere
between I think 4.2 and 4.5 now that's
where purchasing Peaks if the reviews
get any better purchase rates decline
their argument is exactly as you say
which is that Perfection is too good to
be true if you find a kind of a random
supplement brand that you've never heard
of and it gets ten thousand or five star
reviews what's more likely that it's
actually perfect or something's being
manipulated people if they see 4.7 or
4.8 therefore they're more likely to
believe these are honest and give it the
um the the the Credence it deserves so I
think you're right there are some
studies commercially that show
Perfection can be can be off-putting
Peak endral which a lot of people
listening will be familiar with the
original study that was done with
endoscopies colonoscopies I think it was
colonoscopies
not a fun procedure not a fun thing not
not something that normally gets
experimented upon yeah there's a lovely
um corner and radomire study they
recruit a group of people and these are
genuine patients going in for
colonoscopies every patient is given a
handheld device
that buzzes every minute and when it
buzzes the patients have to turn a dial
to say how much pain they're in zero
none at all 10 excruciating
so average time must be last 15 minutes
so they get 15 ratings from what they
call the experiencing self these are in
moment ratings
next they get a rating from the patient
as they're leaving the hospital and then
two months after the operation and that
is another rating reflect on how painful
overall the operation was
the expectation before the study was the
the
average ratings from the remembering
self those reflective ratings
should be roughly the same as the
average rating from the experiencing
self
but that is not what happens the average
amount of pain people experienced is
only a poor guide to what people
remember
what's a much better guide are two
moments in particular the peak moment
the single worst moment of that
operation is disproportionately
important
and the final moments so you could for
example have a low level of pain for 13
minutes and then a medium level of pain
for two minutes
and that person would remember the
experience worse than someone who had a
medium level of pain for 30 minutes and
a low level of pain for for two minutes
at the end
It's the final moments that
disproportionately important it's the
single worst moment that's
disproportionately important in shaping
memory
now that's fascinating because that can
be applied by Brands you might think
Colossus are far too different a a world
but that idea that some moments matter
more than others can be applied to any
brand experience
so a couple of examples I love a
restaurant in London called flat iron
steak restaurant reasonably priced like
15 pounds for estate 20 dollars
you have your steak
well after they've given you the bill
they give you this tiny little pair of
miniature steak knives and they say I'll
just hand these in as you leave it you
hand them into the person the cloak room
by the door and in return they give you
a salty caramel ice cream now most
restaurants end on the worst moment they
end on the bill the paying the faffing
around for splitting the the cash all
that kind of stuff what
Flat Iron do so cleverly is they create
a high for that final moment you leave
and I bet you most people who remember
uh who mostly visit the Flatline will
remember that single instance is the
same thing to do with the effort of it
not just being everybody on the way out
gets a salted caramel ice cream it's
that you have to take the thing get the
thing give it in
oh that's interesting so I was thinking
I wonder if some of the appeal is it's
unexpected and it's surprising it's also
done after the bill it doesn't feel like
it's some kind of commercial transaction
well if you come into my restaurant I'll
give you an ice cream for free that's
just a negotiation this seemingly is
done out of the largest uh uh uh you
know the you know it's done out of the
kind of beauty of their soul as it were
or whatever they don't seem to have an
obvious Financial benefit I wonder if
that makes it so so positive have I told
you about the thing we did with
lollipops at nightclubs
oh I don't think so go on okay so I
learned about the peak end rule
six or seven years ago yeah and we were
encountering a number of challenges one
of them being that a lot of nightclubs
are in high built up city-centered
neighborhood places yeah noise abatement
orders come not only from the sound of
the speakers but also from the sound of
egress when people leave and if you dump
a thousand eighteen-year-olds on the
street at three in the morning they
start chanting things around and scream
and laugh and fight and kick each other
so we needed to come up with a solution
and I tried my best to come up with a
peak end rule that did both of the
things that we needed so what we did was
as people were leaving we had two good
looking girls stood with buckets of
lollipops like just little sweet lollies
giving them a lolly meant that they had
something in their mouth which meant
they were much less likely to start
chanting and singing yeah the sugar high
seemed to have a reduction in the number
of people that hung around afterward
because it gave them enough of a little
bit of energy to get them into a taxi
and home it meant that they didn't hang
around the takeaways and do that stuff
for quite so long and hopefully it gave
them a oh that was wasn't that nice you
remember that lollipop that we gave or
whatever sometimes we give people
um uh
pound coins that had stickers on and the
sticker was a flyer for our uh club
night and if they came back with just
the one pound coin they could get in for
a pound with that one pound coin but
they had to hold on to it that was
something else we tried doing but yeah
that lollipop thing that was pure Peak
Andrew that's a lovely idea do you know
that remind me who you should talk to
um there is an amazing guy called
Stephen Colgan uh I might have
I've got that pronunciation slightly
wrong again
um and he was at the the met I think for
20 years and he was became fascinated
with Behavioral Science and he used all
sorts of Behavioral Science tactics to
reduce crime and I I yeah so the
lollipop idea reminds me of saying that
that he wants uh talks about this whole
idea if you give someone a lollipop
coming out of a nightclub it also makes
them feel a bit like childish and
optimistic they're less likely to punch
someone else in the face
ever had a fight whilst they've got a
lollipop yeah yeah what about uh someone
that's doing something that's less
experiential than a flat iron or a club
night in terms of peak Andrew
um I mean the other one that I've seen
uh apply and it's not all about kind of
sweets I feel like we've come to ice
creams lollies and uh Haribo
um uh wiggle so they're a cycle brand in
in the UK and one of the things they do
you've ordered your fancy helmet and
Lycra they'll put into the order without
telling you you know five pence bag of
Haribo now it's an unexpected delightful
thing at the end of the the journey now
what I think is interesting about this
is most brands think about how do we
make a brilliant first impression
what uh wiggle what your nightclub
example flat iron what they're doing is
saying well yeah maybe first impression
is important but actually if we want
people to come back to our restaurant on
nightclub in a few months time if we end
on a high then much more likely to
remember it so I think it reorders
people's prioritization where they put
their efforts and the second thing it
does is in some organizations this is
the peak part
what they do is they think we've got
these hundred different areas of our
experience a hotel or a restaurant let's
try and make them all a little bit
better
what the peak end rule would suggest is
well you'll Fritter away your budget and
it won't have much of an impact what you
should do instead is think about well
let's put all our budget for our
creative budget into the lollies at the
end or all our budget rather than
slightly better uniforms for the people
at flower and slightly fancy Cutlery
let's put it into the Salted Caramel
idea you know you pick one moment of
Excellence rather than trying to do
everything a little bit better very
interesting I think there are some broad
implications I imagine that both the
peak and the end could be the same thing
as well oh yeah absolutely I mean you
ideally could argue well that if you're
going to create a peak moment best it's
at the first because you get two you two
multipliers on that yeah yeah
um there's a restaurant called Tiki
tatsuya out here in Austin and it's a
sort of tiki Hawaiian themed thing and
every I think it's every hour or every
30 minutes all of the lights shut off
and this huge show occurs where light
projection runs across the ceiling and
this Tiki head bursts into flames and
all sorts of stuff yeah and it's
actually quite intrusive if you're in
the middle of an interesting but it's
done in a really Charming way and it's
kind of fun yeah yeah and I I want to
say it's maybe every half an hour to 45
minutes so it maybe happens twice during
a typical meal uh and Frankenstein's in
Edinburgh which is on I want to say it's
it's just at the top next to the Vodka
revolution
um they have every hour every 90 minutes
uh
automatronic Frankenstein gets lowered
from the ceiling and electric fire
lightning sounds come and then he sits
up and all that [__] happens and it's
kind of cheesy and kind of a bit [__]
but at the same time you go that was
nice that was you I know I've I've
remembered it you know what I mean I've
remembered both of those things to you
if you told me when I went to Dean's
Italian what the peak part of it was
it's like oh well the mashed potato was
pretty nice I guess or whatever there's
nothing there
yes you can argue whether or not you
want the main memory to be the uh
Frankenstein quite coming down from the
ceiling but what you've certainly shown
is you know that that is something that
is at least memorable so the pecan rule
I think suggests
the tactic of doing one thing
excellently rather than Lots things well
and May and ideally putting that at the
final part of your experience
how you then uh create that uh kind of
highlight moment well that then I think
is a little bit of a
subjectivity beautiful Richard shortton
again ladies and gentlemen where should
people go if they want to keep up to
date with all the stuff that you're
doing at the moment oh well I've just
released the book so a book called The
Illusion of choice so you can get that
on Amazon or any of the big retailers
have a look there and then on Twitter at
our shopping
whenever I see an interesting article or
experiment about psychology or
Behavioral Science and how it can be
applied in marketing or advertising I'll
post it up there so either of those
places are good you have one of the
coveted 99 follower spots on my
Instagram very well very well deserved
uh mate I really appreciate you I love
the stuff that you do I can't wait to
see what you do next and when it is
ready you will be coming back on and we
will talk about it again fantastic thank
you very much Chris much appreciated
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace